A RASHIDA TO TLAIB WATCH PARTY.
CONTINUE TO MONITOR THE RALLY
GOING ON IN NORTH CAROLINA FOR
NEWS AND GO BACK TO A LIVE IF
MAKES ANY.
IF PRESIDENT TRUMP IN THE
MEANTIME WERE A FIRE-BREATHING
RACIST, BEN CARSON WOULD
PROBABLY KNOW.
SECRETARY CARSON HAS SERVED
DIRECTLY UNDER THE PRESIDENT FOR
TWO YEARS.
HE JOINS US TONIGHT.
MR. SECRETARY, THANKS VERY MUCH
FOR COMING ON.
AS HE WATCHED THE ALMOST
UNANIMOUS VERDICT OF THE MEDIA
THAT THE PRESIDENT IS A
HARD-BOILED RACIST.
THE PASSWORD IS THIS REALLY BEEN
ALMOST NO OTHER COVERAGE OF
ANYTHING ELSE, WHAT'S YOUR
RESPONSE TO THAT?
>> I'VE NEVER SEEN ANY EVIDENCE
OF THAT WHATSOEVER.
OUR CONVERSATIONS HAVE
FREQUENTLY CENTERED AROUND
DISADVANTAGED PEOPLE IN OUR
COUNTRY AND WHAT WE CAN DO TO
ELEVATE THEM.
AND IT SEEMS TO ME LIKE A RACIST
WOULDN'T SPEND SO MUCH TIME ON
SECOND CHANCE -- WOULDN'T SPEND
SO MUCH TIME -- WITH THOSE
UNREALIZED CAPITAL GAINS INTO
AREAS THAT HAVE TRADITIONALLY
BEEN NEGLECTED SO THAT PEOPLE
CAN RISE.
HE WOULDN'T SPEND SO MUCH TIME
WORKING ON AFFORDABLE HOUSING,
RECOGNIZE WHAT THE CRISIS WAS.
THE LIST GOES ON AND ON.
THESE ARE NOT THINGS THAT PEOPLE
WHO ARE RACIST WOULD DO.
PEOPLE NEED TO LOOK AT WHAT THE
RESULTS ARE AND NOT SPEND ALL OF
THE TIME PARSING EVERY WORD AND
TRYING TO MAKE IT FIT THEIR
NARRATIVE.
>> Tucker: WOULD YOU WORK FOR
A RACIST?
>> I WOULD BE OUT THERE IT IN
TWO SECONDS.
I WOULD NOT.
I CERTAINLY HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SEE WHAT RACISM IS GROWING UP
IN DETROIT AND HE '60s.
>> Tucker: WHY DO YOU THINK
PEOPLE SAY THAT ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT?
>> IN A WAY, IT'S KIND OF NICE
THAT PEOPLE ARE CREATING SUCH A
NICE BINARY CHOICE.
PEOPLE WILL HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO DECIDE DO THEY REALLY LIKE
THE UNITED STATES?
THIS IS A MAGNIFICENT COUNTRY
FOR SOMEONE LIKE ME COULD GROW
UP IN POVERTY, BECOME A BRAIN
SURGEON IN A CABINET MEMBER.
WHY WOULD ANYBODY KNOCK A PLACE
LIKE THAT.
IF IT WAS SUCH A BAD PLACE
PEOPLE WOULDN'T BE FORMING
CARAVANS TO COME HERE.
AND THEN YOU CAN HAVE THE OTHER
CHOICE.
PEOPLE WILL HAVE A VERY, VERY
CLEAR CHOICE.
LET THEM CONTINUE TO FIGHT AND
DEFINE THEMSELVES AND LET THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE DECIDE -- WHAT I
DISCOVERED WHEN I WAS RUNNING
FOR PRESIDENT AS I TRAVELED ALL
OVER THE COUNTRY INTO THE SMALL
LITTLE HAMLETS IN EVERY STATE,
MOST OF THE PEOPLE IN THIS
COUNTRY ACTUALLY HAVE COMMON
SENSE.
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO THROW AWAY
WHAT
>> Tucker: THEY ARE DECENT
KIND OF PEOPLE.
THAT IS THE FIRST THING YOU
DISCOVERED.
DO YOU THINK YOU CAN WIN YOUR
PRESIDENTIAL RACE IF YOU HATE
THE COUNTRY?
>> IT WOULD BECOME VERY APPARENT
WITH YOUR RHETORIC THAT YOU ARE
NOT SOMEONE WHO WAS A SUPPORTER
OF OUR NATION.
AND, YOU KNOW, THE INTERESTING
THING IS WE HAVE AN AMAZING
COUNTRY.
PEOPLE ARE TRYING TO COME HERE
FROM ALL OVER THE WORLD.
THERE IS NO OTHER PLACE LIKE IT.
THERE IS NO PLACE THAT HAS A
HISTORY LIKE OUR COUNTRY.
HAD WE MADE MISTAKES?
ABSOLUTELY.
DO WE LEARN FROM THEM?
IS THAT A REASON TO THROW
EVERYTHING AWAY?
ABSOLUTELY NOT.
PEOPLE WHO CAN ONLY FOCUS ON THE
NEGATIVE ASPECTS OF OUR COUNTRY
AND NOT SEE THE POSITIVE
ASPECTS, YOU HAVE TO WONDER